Hallo ihr Lieben!
Heute gibt's eine Soße wie bei Subway und zwar nehme ich heute meine allerallerliebste.
Die, die Hamza und ich uns immer dazubestellen, nämlich die Sweet Onion Soße.
Die finde ich soo lecker! Ich mag einfach diese Verbindung zwischen süß und Zwiebeln.
Ich finde das passt auch nicht nur zu Sandwiches oder zu Subs sondern auch zu ganz, ganz vielen anderen Dingen!
Daher zeige ich euch jetzt so mein Rezept dafür.
Und das geht auch echt schnell und einfach!
Ich schreibe euch die ganz genauen Mengenangaben hier unten in die Videobeschreibung.
Ich habe vorab nur eine Vorarbeit geleistet
und zwar habe ich meine Zwiebeln richtig schön fein gehackt, dafür nehme ich immer gerne mein Wiegemesser.
Je feiner, desto besser in der Soße.
Und jetzt habe ich hier eine Schüssel mit Wasser und da gebe ich jetzt erstmal alle anderen Zutaten dazu.
Und zwar ganz wichtig für die Süße: Honig.
Dazu gebe ich dann noch ein bisschen Rohrohrzucker.
Anschließend - das kann ich euch auch jetzt schonmal sagen - anschließend etwas Essig,
da habe ich heute Apfelessig genommen.
Und Speisestärke zum Andicken später.
Was auch ganz wichtig ist, ist eine Knoblauchzehe, die werde ich dann einfach reinpressen.
Okay, ihr müsst die Soße nur 3min köcheln lassen, dann wird sie richtig schön dick
aber nicht zu dick, also genauso wie bei Subway.
Jetzt hab ich einmal rote Zwiebeln verwendet, einfach weil ich rote Zwiebeln geschmacklich präferiere
aber dadurch ändert sich halt die Farbe komplett in Dunkelrot.
Und originalgetreu ist es dann halt mit weißen Zwiebeln, da hab ich hier beide Varianten.
Weiße Zwiebeln sind einfach optisch eher wie bei Subway, geschmacklich sind beide top.
Also unbedingt nachmachen und wie gesagt auch für andere Sachen verwenden!
Wenn ihr euch mal ein Sandwich macht oder egal was, macht die Sweet Onion Soße nach!
Die ist mwah! Super, super lecker!
Und ich entlasse euch jetzt und wir sehen uns ja morgen bei meinem nächsten Subway Rezept.
Ansonsten schaut auf jeden Fall unten in die Videobeschreibung.
Da schreibe ich euch alles hin, was ich an Produkten benutzt habe, alle Zutaten,
die Playlist für Subway Rezepte und - ja!
Bis zum nächsten Mal auf Kikis Kitchen! Tschüss!